in the comic hero's journey you have
these seven steps that the comic heroes
goes through there's you start with the
normal world you then go to WTF
something impossible or improbable
happens then there's a reaction
connections disconnections new
directions and race to the finish and we
can go through all of those and see how
it applies to a classic movie like
Groundhog Day and a new movie like spy
or Tropic Thunder or this is the end so
in the normal world we see our main
character who is broken or or they're
lacking something and and we get a
glimpse of who they are
Michael Haig in his work likes to talk
about essence and identity my
terminologies is different but it's the
same it's the same idea masks to match
in the first act the first part of the
comic hero's journey you see a character
have a flash of who they really should
be there's a moment in Groundhog Day
when Bill Murray first sees Andie
MacDowell Rita the producer and all of a
sudden you can see in his eyes that
there's a change that's happened to him
but it's just a flash it's just kind of
a flash of who they might be their mask
is taken off and for a moment you can
see the Mensch that they're gonna be in
spy Melissa McCarthy is guiding Jude Law
through a series of fights in in a in a
mansion and you can see how good she
really is how really capable she is in
terms of what she knows and what you can
do but it's just a second and then she
goes back to being all fluttery when he
says something nice
to her and she's she goes back to her
sense of her not being enough so you
have this sense of who these people are
the other thing that happens in the
normal world is you also get a sense of
the theme you hear the theme echo and
re-echo in these moments in spy melissa
mccarthy is sitting with her best friend
nancy at the CIA cafeteria i guess and
she's talking about the lessons that she
melissa mccarthy's talking about the
lessons she got from her mother and her
mother used to put a little note in her
in her lunch box you will never achieve
the dreams that you have for yourself
and in a sense that's that's the theme
of spy is is having the courage to
follow your own dreams and at this point
in the movies Melissa McCarthy was
playing this CIA analyst Susan Cooper
doesn't feel like she can measure up to
the glamorous spy Karen Walker or Jude
Law's by Bradley v and in Groundhog Day
for instance he's when Bill Murray first
gets to Punxsutawney he's walking down
the street and he meets the obnoxious
insurance salesman played by Stephen
Tobolowsky and one of the things that
Stephen Tobolowsky says to him in
talking about being an insurance
salesman and selling him insurance is
Stephen Tobolowsky says you know a lot
of my friends are into actuarial zs--
but I say it's all big one crapshoot
anywho and that's that's a line that
that echoes what the theme is going to
be is that what what is their future
what what what can we make our future
can we predict our future and can we
change our future because ultimately
that's what is going to be happening in
Groundhog Day is a man's going to have
to live the same day over and over again
and not be able to move on to this
future so after the normal world you
have the what-the-fuck moment the WTF
moment
you